today's video is brought to you by
crossout more on them in a bit
so welcome back to our biographic series
on pompeii the great one of the most
significant figures in the history of
ancient rome his career was so prolific
that we just had to give it the
super-sized treatment this is part two
of a two-parter do make sure you check
out the first part if you haven't seen
it yet because otherwise this one's not
gonna make a lot of sense is it
the last time we saw our intrepid hero
he had just won the sartorian war this
alone was worthy of another military
triumph back in rome but pompe was not
the kind of guy to just sit back and
take it easy when it was fighting to be
had during the years that pompeii had
been away in hispania a slave rebellion
had erupted in italy in 73 bc started by
a few dozen escaped gladiators from a
training school a capua led by a dude
named spartacus at first this was of no
particular concern after all slave
uprisings happened all the time and we
usually crush quickly mercilessly this
one however was different before long
the gladiators were joined by tens of
thousands of other warriors as they led
raids all over italy the senate solution
was to send a praetor named glaber after
them with a force of poorly trained
poorly equipped militia thinking that it
would do the trick in fact it did not do
the trick it fumbled the trick worse
than a drunk magician on one dollar beer
night glib's militia was annihilated by
spartacus's forces and then another prey
tour sent on a second expedition
suffered the exact same fate if anything
they were helping the gladiator's cause
because his men equipped themselves with
the weapons and armor of the dead romans
while word spread of the mighty
spartacus and made even more people join
him the following year rome sent two
consular legions after the slaves no
more militia this time around these were
proper roman soldiers and yet the same
thing happened by 71 bc the senate
realized they were in a spot of bother
by dismissing the revolt in its early
stages they allowed it to grow to
dangerous levels some estimated that
spartacus's army may have exceeded a
hundred thousand men and they could be
thinking about marching on rome itself
this was the time when pompeii would
have come in handy but he was still in
espana at this point therefore the
senate turned to their second best
option marcus crassus pompeo and crassus
had fought together under sula and
enjoyed a frenemy relationship they
often had to compete for the same goals
but overall they both benefited more
from having the other one around than
getting rid of them crassus accepted the
task of ridding rome of spartacus and
his slave army and this time there were
no half-measures crassus went after his
target with eight legions of roman
soldiers plus tens of thousands of
auxiliaries crassus gained the upper
hand in the conflict and at one point
had trapped spartacus and his army in
brutium and launched a war of attrition
hoping to starve them out things were
going well until crassus received
terrible news he was getting
reinforcements but hold on a minute
wouldn't that be good news well no not
really because the reinforcements
consisted of pompeii and his army he had
finished his work in espana just in time
to take part in the dale end of the
gladiator war and collect his share of
the credit unsurprisingly crassus wanted
the glory for himself but on the other
side spartacus wasn't thrilled with the
idea either since it meant fighting two
armies instead of one therefore the two
camps met in combat once and for all at
the battle of solarius river crassus was
triumphant and spartacus presumably was
killed in battle since his body was
never recovered and yet it was pompeii
who had the last laugh a few thousand
slaves managed to slip past crassus
forces and they walked right into
bombay's army which was just arriving to
join in the fray after he diligently
slaughtered every last one of them
pompey sent word to the senate saying
that krasus had conquered the gladiators
in pitched battle but that he himself
had extrapolated the war entirely this
was technically correct which is the
best kind of correct but he was clearly
exaggerating his role in the matter
while minimizing that of crassus the
latter had no choice but to just green
and bear it he knew that pompeii was
more popular than him and he didn't want
to come off as bitter and complaining
therefore when they arrived in rome
crassus just sat back and watched the
city throw another triumph in pompeii's
honor although truth be told it was
mainly for his actions in the satorian
war and not the slave rebellion once it
was over crassus approached pompeii with
a smile on his face and an extended
handshake and made clear his true
intentions he wanted his support for the
position of consul and pompeii was happy
to give it to him in fact both men were
put forward as candidates for the
console ship the following year
technically pompeii should not have been
eligible both due to his young age and
because he had never held any of the
lesser officers but the entire curse of
sonorum went out the window when it came
to pompeii ultimately a special decree
was passed and in 70 bc both men were
elected consoles the most significant
thing that pompey did during his time as
consul was to bring back the plebeian
tribune or the tribune of the people
historically this was the first office
in rome open to commoners and it was
also their greatest check on the power
of the upper classes since the tribune
could veto the decisions of the senate
and even the consuls sulla did away with
the position but both pompei and crassus
agreed to restore it to the tremendous
pleasure of the roman people apparently
it was the only act during their one
year term which the two powerful consuls
cooperated on
[Music]
once pompey's consulship was over he was
ready to put down the pen and pick up
the sword again he was still in his
prime after all so there was no reason
for him to give up the military life
that he loved so much surely rome was
always embroiled in one conflict or
another and now was no exception as the
republic was fighting the third
mithridatic war against mithridates vi
the king of pontus nowadays mithridates
isn't particularly well known which is a
bit unfair since he was one of rome's
most formidable opponents during its
republic years he had been a thorn in
their side for decades and had waged his
first war with rome against sulla back
then sulla had the upper hand and could
have probably eradicated the problem
completely however he was rushing to get
back to rome to deal with that pesky
civil war so he hastily agreed to a
treaty with mithridates then in 83 bc
the second war started but this one was
relatively brief and proved inconclusive
before each side retreated deep into its
own territory again that's how we
arrived at the third and final
mithridatic war the longest of the bunch
it started in 74 bc when mithridates
invaded the neighboring kingdom of
bithenia this was intended to become a
roman province but if you're good at
remembering dates you might recall that
at that time pompeii was in hispania
fighting the satorian war so he couldn't
also go to anatolia to fight the kingdom
of pontus therefore the two consuls of
that year lucius lysinius lucillus and
marcus aurelius cotter were sent to deal
with the problem and they did a pretty
good job they defeated mithridates and
pushed him back several times but they
couldn't deal with the threat
permanently by 69 bc the war was still
going hot and pompeii was raring to go
but there was just one problem there
were no vacancies mithridates was one of
the republic's greatest enemies and
taking him down would have been a major
feather in the cap or you know laurel
reef of a military commander the guy
could pull that off well he knew he was
going to get a biographics video 2000
years later and so did every other roman
general nobody was willing to give up
their spot in the war for pompeii but
that was okay because he had another foe
to fight pirates over the last couple of
decades pirates in the mediterranean had
become an ever-increasing problem for
rome they were responsible for attacks
on vital grain ships as well as taking
prominent romans prisoner and holding
them for ransom the most famous example
was julius caesar who was captured in 75
bc and held captive for over a month
like spartacus and his gladiators the
pirates started out as a minor nuisance
because of this rome assumed it could
deal with them at any time so it left
them unchecked until they became a
serious threat plutarch estimated that
at the height of their power the pirates
had over 1 000 ships and controlled 400
cities several roman commanders tried to
subdue the marauders and failed and in
67 bc one fleet of pirates got so cocky
that they sailed up the mouth of the
tiber and attacked the port austere near
rome itself such an act was considered a
great humiliation for the republic that
couldn't even protect the waters near
its capital therefore an extraordinary
move was made a new law was passed alex
gabinia which conferred great powers on
a pro-consul and gave him always
complete control over the port cities in
the mediterranean sea this was
accompanied by significant financial
resources and a large fleet in order to
deal with the pirates and the man who
gained these remarkable privileges was
none other than pompeii not everyone was
thrilled with the decision and many
fought fervently to stop the law from
passing they were uncomfortable with the
idea of one person having all of that
authority and to be fair they had a
point just in the last 20 years or so
there have been several men who rebelled
against rome's status quo and tried to
take power for themselves fortunately
for the senate pompeii was not one such
man sure he wanted all the power the
money and glory that he could get but he
was content with doing it within the
bounds established by the roman republic
in terms of pure efficiency this might
have been pompe's finest hour he had 200
ships at his disposal and as many
soldiers as he needed he divided the
mediterranean into 13 districts and each
one was assigned a number of ships led
by a commander he trusted meanwhile
pompei himself traveled with his 60 best
ships to cilicia on the southern coast
of anatolia since that was the biggest
pirate haven within 40 days most of the
seas were free of pirates pompeii showed
great mercy to those he captured which
prompted many others to surrender
willingly since they knew the good times
were over pompeii then needed just a few
more months to track down the ones who
refused to submit peacefully overall it
was a great success for pompei and it
was followed by even more good news
because the senate was starting to think
that maybe he should deal with
mithridates after all now just before we
continue with today's video let me take
a moment to tell you about the sponsor
of this episode crossout what is
crossout well it's a vehicle shooter
game as in you drive a tank like
creation around and you try to blow up
other people's tank-like creations but
it goes beyond that because all of the
vehicles are made by the players and
this isn't somewhere select from 20
options and change the paint sort of
thing you can really customize it
however you want to build your vehicle
from the ground up indeed i built mine
so badly initially that they were like
it's got too many guns and off batteries
it just isn't gonna work but you get the
hang of it pretty quickly and then you
go to battle and in battle you'll see
some truly wacky creations from other
players throw on a chainsaw if you want
but there's also plasma weapons like
tons and tons of options there's also
different game modes so for me i like to
jump in for a quick battle 10 minute
break from work it's nice but there's
also longer battles you can play as well
as racing battle royale fights and much
more so look crossout is free it's a lot
of fun and if you use my link below
you'll get an exclusive bonus as well as
a choice between three weapons you'll
get unique pixel plane as well as a
choice between three weapons as well as
a powerful vehicle cabin like i say link
below it's free why not and now back to
today's video
it was in early 66 bc that a tribune
named manilius began suggesting that
rome turned over its eastern command to
pompeii as we said the previous guy
locules was doing all right but he
suffered a major setback in 67 bc when
he lost an important battle that turned
the tide to mithridates favor some were
even accusing lucillus of prolonging the
war intentionally so that he could loot
and plunder as much as possible a new
law was passed laxmanilia which made it
official pompeii was now in charge
apparently when he heard of his new
appointment pompey reacted with mock
histrionics bemoaning the fact that he's
always the one who has to take on these
massive challenges he said alas for my
endless tasks how much better it were to
be an unknown man if i am never to cease
from my military service and cannot lay
aside this load of envy and spend my
time in the country with my wife this
was all for show of course any close
friend of pompeii understood that this
was basically his dream job and
certainly pompeii wasted no time in
raising an army and marching east
towards anatolia he stopped at every
kingdom and province along the way not
only to continue building his forces but
also to undo everything la solas had
done he rewarded those that lacillus had
punished and punished those that he had
favored if nothing else it was just to
show everyone that lucille's was now as
weak as a newborn lamb and that pompeii
was the new head honcho there wasn't
much losulus could do about it but he
did insult pompei by comparing him to a
lazy carrion bird who feasted on the
bodies that others had killed referring
here to the fact that he always joined
wars towards the end after other men
such as crassus metallus and catalysts
had done the work it's an interesting
idea and it might be a valid criticism
it's also what definitely happened in
this case by the time pompe made his
appearance in 65 bc the kingdom of
pontus was mainly under roman control
and the fighting always taking place in
its neighboring allied kingdoms such as
armenia cultures and iberia pompeii
started his campaign by fighting
mithridates at the battle of lysis in
ionia it was a decisive victory for
pompeii and he forced his opponent to
fall back and retreat it to the
mountains mithradartes was hoping that
his allies would keep pompeii busy while
he raised a new army but he was wrong on
both counts his allies proved no match
for the roman might a few more battles
occurred in 65 bc all won by pompeii and
victory at the battle of abbas against
the kingdom of albania turned out to be
the last open engagement of the campaign
meanwhile mithridates was not successful
in reinforcing his army it seems that
the local forces have been all but
exhausted and those who remained were
fed up with years and years of war even
the king's own sons rebelled against
their father so with no other prospects
mithridates vi committed suicide in 63
bc half of the kingdom of pontus was
annexed by rome and together with
bethenia it was turned into a new roman
province pompeii had won the mithridatic
war but he wasn't finished since he was
already in the area and still had an
army itching for a fight why not put it
to good use he captured syria turning it
into another roman province he also
attacked judea annexing half of it and
rendering the other half into a
powerless vassal state he then liberated
hundreds of small towns settlements and
strongholds and completely reorganized
rome's eastern defensive frontier into a
new system that stayed in place for
hundreds of years pompeii had no
authority to do any of this by the way
officially his reasoning was that the
region was unstable and that this was a
threat to rome's new eastern possessions
but many feared that he had completely
given in to his insatiable lust for
power and glory and that soon after rome
would be next
the entire senate collectively breathed
a sigh of relief in december 62 bc when
they found out that pompeii had reached
brundicium in southern italy and had
disbanded his army he paid his soldiers
sent them on their merry way and went
off on a sort of celebration tour
throughout italy suffice to say that he
expected another triumph when he reached
rome his actions against the pirates and
against mithridates were more than
enough to warrant such festivities but
this was the biggest triumph in the
history of rome cassia's d.o referred to
it as the great event and said that
pompeii had a trophy for every single
war he won and then a giant one quote
decked out in costly fashion and bearing
an inscription stating that it was a
trophy of the inhabited world plutarch
gave a more detailed account that truly
highlighted the extent of pompei's
conquests he said his triumph had such a
magnitude that although it was
distributed over two days still the time
would not suffice inscriptions born in
advance of a procession integrated the
nations over which he triumphed these
were pontus armenia cappadocia falgonia
media culture siberia albania syria
cilicia mesopotamia phoenicia and
palestine judea arabia and all the power
of the pirates among these people no
less than a thousand strongholds have
been captured in cities not much under
900 in number beside 800 piratical ships
while 39 cities have been founded to put
it simply rome had never seen a champion
the likes of pompey the great in spite
of this or more likely because of this
pompeii didn't wield a lot of political
influence he wanted the senate to ratify
and recognize all the city's vassal
states and kings that he installed in
the east but they were reluctant to do
so many senators had been wary for years
of all the power granted to pompeii so
they thought it best to cut him down to
size a little bit there wasn't much
pompe could do about it he was at home
on the battlefield not in the senate
house he knew he didn't have the
political muscle to take on its
detractors but that would soon change
around 60 bc a powerful alliance was
formed the first tromboras an informal
coalition between three of rome's
wealthiest most influential and most
popular figures pompeii marcus crassus
and julius caesar the goal was for each
one to support the interests of the
other two but it's pretty clear that
caesar got the most out of their little
on taunt first he was given the
consulship in 59 bc then he was made a
governor and finally he was sent to
fight in the gallic wars on his end the
trauma enabled pompeii to get his
eastern settlements ratified and land
grants provided for his veterans he was
also appointed consul again in 55 bc and
enjoyed a five-year stint as prefectus
anony a important position that placed
him in charge of the grain supply to
rome despite its effectiveness from the
beginning the alliance was tenuous at
best pompei and crassus never truly
liked each other pompe and caesar grew
closer when the former married the
latter's daughter julia however she died
during childbirth in 54 bc and the
relationship between pompei and caesar
turned decidedly frostier from then on
the following year the trumbet
officially ended after crassus died at
the battle of carhei against the
parthian empire and then a war erupted
that changed the course of history
forever
look we're not going to go into a
massive preamble about the start of the
civil war that has more to do with
caesar than it does to do with pompeii
and we already have a bio on julius
caesar if you want that story in full
suffice to say that in 49 bc caesar
crossed the rubicon after winning the
gaelic wars he refused a demand from the
senate to disband his troops and marched
into italy with an army from that point
on civil war became inevitable all those
years the senate feared that this was
something that pompey would do although
he never did and now that caesar had
done it they rushed to pompei for help
he agreed but was caught off guard by
the rapid pace at which caesar advanced
toward rome when the two sides first met
in battle at the siege of brundicium an
outmanned and ill-prepared pompei
suffered one of his greatest defeats
this gave pompei the dark realization
that he could not defend rome so he
abandoned the city and fled to macedonia
to properly mobilize his forces he set
up his camp in the city of diraccia in
modern-day albania caesar besieged the
city in 48 bc but after months of
inconclusive skirmishes he conceded
defeat and made a strategic retreat thus
tying their score at one all the great
decider occurred in august of that year
at the battle of fasalas in central
greece pompei didn't want to do it he
thought he was rushing things but his
allies all pressured him to meet up with
a confederate named metallia scepio and
take out caesar but that's not how
things went down pompeii's plan was to
make use of his large cavalry attack
caesar's right wing from the flank go
around the rear of the enemy and trap
them between two armies however caesar
shrewdly guessed pompey's strategy and
reinforced his right wing but kept his
extra soldiers out of sight until it was
too late for pompeii's men they pounced
at the right time and brought chaos
confusion and death to pompei's cavalry
units they retreated in a panic and from
that moment on the battle was as good as
lost it was undoubtedly pompe's greatest
defeat he escaped the battlefield
disguised as a civilian and fled to
egypt thinking that the ptolemies were
friendly and would help him rebuild his
army but they had already chosen their
side on september 28 48 bc just one day
short of his 58th birthday pompey
disembarked at alexandria and was
immediately waylaid by assassins who
stabbed him to death right on the dock
they cut up his head and threw his body
in the ocean a freed man loyal to
pompeii fished out his corpse and gave
him a modest funeral caesar himself was
appalled by this act and burst into
tears when he was presented with
pompeii's head and seal ring he demanded
pompe's assassins and had them put to
death and that was the anonymous end
of one of history's greatest military
careers